Yo, what's up, everyone? Welcome to this latest episode of Critical Thinking Bug Bounty Podcast.
As always, I'm your host, Justin Gardner, and co-host Joel Margolis is currently not here today.
So we brought on a great guest, Corbin Leo, amazing hacker, wonderful methodology.
So I think you'll really enjoy what he's got to say this episode.
But before we dive into it, I wanted to ask you to head over to criticalthinkingpodcast.io
and subscribe to our newsletter.
What that's going to do is it's going to give you access to a text version of the content
that we've been producing here, produced by none other than Jesse Rivera himself.
So during the nice little intro song that we've got here,
pull out your phone, head over to criticalthinkingpodcast.io and drop a subscribe.
Hope you enjoy the episode.
Yo, yo, yo. Welcome to the pod, Corbin.
Thanks. Thanks for having me. Excited to be here.
Thanks for stepping in last minute.
We had Joel disappear on us this week.
He had some family stuff coming up.
So I texted Corbin yesterday at like 9 p.m.
and be like, yo, can you get on the pod tomorrow morning?
So appreciate you stepping in, man.
Of course.
All right.
So I've got a bunch of questions for you.
And I hope...
Did you grab a report, by the way?
Yeah, I have one in mind.
Okay, cool.
Nice.
I was going to go to my collaboration stuff
and see if we could find one that we worked on together.
But yeah, if you've got one, that works too.
Okay.
So first, let's go ahead and do the news section.
So how this works, Corbin, is we...
First, we do the news.
And then I ask you a bunch of questions
that I've got in the doc about your life and your hacker vibes.
But since we've got no Joel today,
you're stepping in and you're doing the news with us.
All righty.
So first thing that I had on the list here,
and this is pretty cool.
I really like just DNS rebinding as a concept.
But there was an article that came out earlier this week
called State of DNS Rebinding in 2023.
And actually, I think it got released
actually about a month ago now,
but it just came across my feed.
This was by an NCC group.
And essentially, it's exactly what it sounds like,
a State of DNS Rebinding article.
And it talks about all of the different
restrictions that they have in the space.
There's local network requests,
which is a new restriction that's coming into place.
Unfortunately, in this upcoming version of Chrome,
we're about to lose access to a bunch of local network stuff.
But just to sort of summarize it,
there's going to be some core stuff that's going to start coming into play
on local network access.
And this is already in what is called a Chrome depreciation trial,
which essentially allows for us to have a developer token
that you request if you still need this feature
so that they can still sort of gradually roll it out
and not break everything.
So that was something I'd never heard of before
and I thought was pretty interesting.
Let's see.
What else is there here?
Yeah.
Good thing all these bug bounty programs
aren't outdated versions of Chrome still, right?
Yeah, I know, right?
Yeah, they still have, like, you know,
a lot of times what you run into in those sort of situations
is, like, super mega old Chromes
and that becomes the problem, right?
It's like, oh, man, how do I hack this thing
that doesn't have any of the features
I've been used to for the past, you know,
six or seven versions?
Let me see what else I had here on the notes.
So, yeah, this is something that we talked about
when we did the episode on rebind multi-A.
And that is that Chrome can...
There is a rebind that you can do in Chrome
that's instant with using a record
that has multiple IP addresses that it resolves to
and that can rebind only to 0.0.0.0,
which is, like, sort of a private IP address.
I mean, technically, you can access local services,
but it's not necessarily specifically a loopback
or local IP address space.
So there's a Chrome issue
that we'll link in the description
saying specifically, you know,
tracking that specific vulnerability.
But as of right now,
the takeaways from that article
are that you can still attack services
on 0.0.0.0 using Singularity
or my DNS rebinding tool.
And then the other thing that I didn't know
was that the WebSocket port scanner still works.
So you can still do timing attacks
against local services
and services on the local network
using a WebSocket port scanner,
which I thought was pretty rad.
That's cool.
Makes sense.
Yep.
Let's see what else we got here.
Yeah.
So let's see.
Douglas Day,
Archangel D-Day,
is his Twitter handle,
posted a Twitter thread,
which I know Corbin loves, right?
It's been a while.
Yeah.
And he dropped 100
very short bug bounty rules.
And I think at the end of the tweet,
he kind of linked to
a Ryan Holiday tweet
where he got that sort of
flow from.
But this is a really cool tweet
that has a bunch of really nice advice
for what you would do
if you were, you know,
100 different rules for bug bounty
and what kind of stuff
you should try to approach.
So I figured let's go ahead
and take a peek at these real quick,
Corbin,
and read through some of these
and give these a talk.
So one of the ones
that popped out to me
was give yourself
a no bug limit.
I do three hours.
So he said that like,
if you don't find a bug
within three hours
on a specific part
of the target,
you move along.
What do you think about that, man?
I mean,
I think that's,
I think that makes sense.
I mean,
I don't think I'd,
I don't do three hours.
Maybe I should,
but it's just like,
okay,
I'm kind of sick of looking at this.
I'm going to look at something else.
So you move along pretty quickly.
Yeah,
I move on decently,
decently quickly.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Especially when it's like
a really big app.
If it's bigger,
then it's like,
okay,
I don't see anything.
I don't know.
I tend to,
like some people do more
of like the pen tester methodology
where it's like,
okay,
I'm going to test this specific thing
for literally everything.
Whereas it's like,
okay,
I'm going to like,
just check out
the different functionality
and then I'm going to like,
I don't know,
go where like my Spidey senses
like are tingling in one area.
So like,
I'm going to go look at this
and then,
okay,
I don't see anything here
and I just kind of do that.
I feel like you have
a pretty strong hacker Spidey sense,
which I think,
you know,
we'll touch on a little bit later
in the flow,
but I'm definitely interested
in trying to crack that nut
a little bit
because when I read
through your threads
and just when I've seen you,
you know,
at the live hacking events
and such,
I feel like you find bugs
that are pretty different
from what I find.
So I think our methodology
sort of deviates
a little bit there
and you're a little bit,
a little bit more recon heavy,
which is cool.
Let's see what else we got here.
Oh, okay.
So this is another one
that I thought was pretty cool.
24.
It says six,
six 1k mediums
pay more than one 5k crit.
Don't ignore any bugs.
And I think this one
is kind of like once
because there's a certain
brand of hacker
that just kind of
only reports highs
and crits
and that's great.
But I totally agree
with Douglas here
that there are a lot of people
and even ignoring lows
I think is a mistake
because one,
that's value
you could have
in your pocket
and two,
if the company
is going to pay for it,
it's something that they want.
It's something that they think
would secure up
their attack surface.
So I would say
never, never
don't report a bug
that you think might be valid.
Yeah, and I agree with that.
I mean,
there's sometimes,
I guess it kind of depends.
Like if you find
a stumble across
medium or low bug,
why would you not report it?
Because it's just like,
yeah, you might get duped,
but hey,
there's a chance you're not
and I guess that's like
free money.
But yeah,
then there's other people
that just don't even
look for mediums
or anything like lower
than that too.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like I stumble
across mediums or lows
when I'm looking
for higher impact bugs.
Yeah, same here.
That's the kind of thing
that I like,
you know,
when I'm,
and I've talked about this
on our episode,
I'll have to pull it up
right here,
the episode where we talk
about how to find
a good program,
episode 13.
I kind of talk about this,
you know,
whenever I'm choosing
a program,
I always try to pick
a program that has
good payments for lows
and mediums as well.
Because as you're going
after those highs and crits,
you're always going to
stumble upon the lows
and the mediums.
And it's just nice
to have a good consistent,
you know,
influx of bounties
coming in to keep you
motivated and to keep
your, you know,
wallet full if you're
a full-time bike bounty hunter.
Yep, exactly.
I think like the,
the inverse of this problem
too is like when you're
only looking for like
lows and mediums
and other people who like,
I guess I don't know
like anyone specifically
who does that.
But I mean,
I guess that's a mistake
too is,
I guess that might just be
like kind of like
a beginner thing as well.
Yeah, I think it's just
a beginner thing too.
It's trying to like crack
to find like bigger
and bigger things.
So, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think it,
I think it can,
I think it can go,
you know,
if you're just not
dreaming big enough
in your attack vector
mentality as well.
Like if you're never
thinking,
like for example,
I,
I very rarely,
I used to very rarely
look for arbitrary
account takeover,
right?
Because I was like,
this bug is just kind
of like a myth,
right?
Like does this really
exist though?
And then like,
you know,
I see you
and OXACB
and some of the other
hackers out there
that just kind of
have a different
mentality start popping
some of the stuff
at live hacking events
and I'm like,
oh, wow.
Literally,
OXACB,
like I love it,
man.
He literally,
I think you know
the one I'm talking
about.
Yeah,
I know exactly
what you're talking
about.
That one was
actually insane.
That was absurd.
I thought that
couldn't be done.
Like literally
15 year legacy
code where he
popped an arbitrary
account takeover
just because it was
like a,
it was like a
string contains bug
rather than a
string equals bug,
which is crazy.
So that one was,
yeah,
that one blew my mind.
I think keeping,
keeping the attack
vector mentality high
is another really
good solid tip.
Well,
yeah,
and also don't like
put restrictions
on ideas before
you try it too.
It's like,
oh,
there's no way
that could work.
It's like,
you'd be surprised
by how much
code is just
like strung
together with
who knows what.
Devs do crazy
shit sometimes.
They really do.
And there's just
weird services that
interpret things
differently.
Like,
you never know.
Yeah.
So I knew,
I know I kind of
threw this on you
last second here
with the tweet,
but you see any
of these that
stand out to you
in particular?
Um,
let me see.
I mean,
I think
let's see.
Um,
let's see,
36.
You find a bug
that's out of scope.
Like,
this is a whole
another,
this 36,
you could talk
about so much
more too,
is like,
what is it?
If you find a bug
that's out of scope,
still ask the customer
if they care.
Um,
I've,
I don't know,
that's a really
tough,
tough one
because like,
there's obviously
reasons you have
scope sections
in,
you know,
programs have scope
sections.
You don't want them
hacking,
you know,
like third party.
Um,
obviously there's like,
you might have to find
an RC on something,
but like it,
it's contained as a
sandbox.
It has like,
access to nothing.
There's plenty of
still like out of scope
things that have like
an insane impact
that the customer
might not know
about too.
Um,
yeah.
So you say don't ask
the customer if they
care,
just submit the bug
or what do you,
what are you saying?
Not necessarily.
It's like,
I don't know.
It's,
it's really difficult
because,
um,
like you shouldn't
just go like
hacking out of scope
stuff just for the
sake of hacking
out of scope
stuff.
Um,
but at the same
time,
I don't know.
I don't want to get
into this.
I feel like you do
that Corbin.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's lots of times
I've had some pretty
good bugs by going
a bit out of scope
and to be fair,
it's a program that
has like,
that has had a
VIP section
where they have
only a certain
number of
assets that are in
scope for the
VIP pain program.
They also have a
VDP.
It's like with that
program,
um,
it's a lot easier
to do this.
Um,
but I've had like
instances of like
a domain that
isn't even related
to that company.
Um,
and it was actually,
it turns out
it was owned by
them.
Um,
it was somehow
linked to this
like one asset,
this like production
database of all
their like customers.
And it was like,
um,
this huge like
information leakage
that was by some
like,
it was way out of
scope.
I don't even think
it was listed in
their like VDP
program,
but it was still
owned by them.
Um,
and so like that
one was paid for
their max,
uh,
like a max crit
inside their VIP
program,
even though it
wasn't even like
listed in scope.
Wow.
Um,
but then I've also
had like,
um,
and other companies
will have like
internal host names
that they use
for networking,
you know,
inside like Kubernetes
pods just within
their like corporate
network.
Um,
and there'll be
times that there's
like assets that
are still on the
internet with like
SSL certificates
linked to those
and you can still
hit those and
like there's like
vulnerabilities on
those apps that
like,
okay,
it's not listed in
scope,
but hey,
this is like
really bad.
This is like
internal like
infrastructure.
There's like
lots of like
sensitive information.
I don't know.
You can find
like bugs in
these apps that
where it's like
really bad
and they still
care about that.
I feel like
that's kind of
crazy,
you know,
right?
Because like
if they list
something and
you never really
know for sure
unless you
know,
unless you're
internal,
but if they
list something
like,
okay,
www
is in scope
and www
is just
reverse proxy
to this
back-end,
you know,
API that
they have
that is on
a different
domain.
And so
literally
everything that
www,
every piece
of functionality
that www
has,
you know,
is getting
routed through
this API,
but that
back-end piece,
if you access
it directly,
it's not in
scope,
that doesn't
really make
any sense.
Yeah,
it's like
example.com
forward slash
API is
actually just
reverse proxy
into api.example.com
that's not listed
in scope and
it's just like,
I don't know,
it gets weird.
It does get
weird.
It gets weird
fast there.
I think,
and I think
one other one
that just popped
out to me
and then we'll
move along
to the next
little thing
here is
if an app
is number
28,
if an app
uses UUIDs,
you can still
look for IDORs,
just set AC
to high.
And I think
this is one
of the mistakes
that I made
early on
is not realizing
that,
is that,
you know,
some programs
will say,
hey,
UUID IDORs
aren't going
to be a thing,
but that's
literally what
the attack
complexity high
metric was made
for.
It's like,
hey,
there's some
piece of this
attack that
requires some
state to be,
the application
to be in some
state or some
piece of information
that I don't
know,
but it's
reasonable for
me to get.
And so,
you know,
these sort of
IDs in these
IDOR scenarios
aren't really
being treated
as sensitive
information.
so it's
definitely,
I think,
falls within
the scope
of AC
access control
high to
report that.
To be fair,
I wouldn't
really even
call it,
I don't know
if I'd call
it an IDOR
or if I'd
just call it
an access control
bug.
Oh,
really?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Maybe not.
I mean,
I guess it's
still,
I guess,
an IDOR.
I just think
like,
when people
think of IDORs,
because I mean,
it's like,
you're still,
you're just
referencing another
object,
but I mean,
I don't know,
I guess with
a lot of
programs,
like a lot of
people just
when they think
of IDORs,
they think it's
like,
okay,
I can just
increment,
decrement a number.
And sometimes
I've had success
where I just say
like,
hey,
it's an access
control bug
and it kind
of clicks
for them
because they're
like,
oh,
wait,
you can't
just easily
get this
UID,
but you can
find ways
to leak it
still.
And you still
shouldn't be able
to access it,
so sometimes
just framing
it,
access control
issue or lack
of access
control or
something like
that.
It's just
like an easier
way to present
it to someone
who might,
you know,
just not,
yeah.
Yeah,
not get the
full picture
for sure.
Yeah,
and that kind
of goes into
like 41
when it just
says like,
spend the extra
time making
your report
look or read
nice,
just write
well,
write clearly
because,
I mean,
this whole
thing is about
communication,
so.
Funny you should
mention that,
Corbin,
because I have
on my list
of notes
about,
you know,
about you
when I did
my little,
you know,
OS int
on Corbin
before this
episode.
I,
one of the
things that
really stood
out to me
a lot is
your propensity
for storytelling
and writing
and combining
that with
hacking.
And so,
tell you what,
let's finish
the news
section and
then I'll
come back
to that
real quick.
Okay.
No worries.
Real quick,
so definitely
check out
that tweet
by Arch
angle,
it's
arch angle,
arch,
please say
it for me,
Corbin,
please.
Like Arch
angel.
Arch
Thank you.
I couldn't
say arch
angle.
Arch
angel.
Geez.
Sorry.
You know,
like I get
that.
Arch
arch
angel
D-Day
is his
handle on
Twitter.
Go check
it out.
It's a
great,
great tweet.
Okay.
Next one
that I wanted
to talk
about was
the service
called
TalkBack.
This is
actually put
out by
LTAM,
one of the
companies that
we mentioned
before on
the pod.
And this
is just a
news aggregator
for cybersecurity
related,
infosec related
content.
And I've just
got this
favorited and
I'll pop this
open every
couple of
days and
just kind of
scroll through
the last
couple of
days of
news.
I just
wanted to
throw that
out there
because it
seems like
a pretty
good resource.
I don't
think it's
caught on
as much.
So I'm
hoping that
people will
start using
it a little
bit more.
And yeah,
it's not
necessarily
bug bounty
oriented,
but it is
infosec
oriented.
So for those
of you that
have a
little bit
broader
horizon than
just bug
bounty,
that's a
good place
to look.
Let's
see.
Last thing
on the news
item for
today was
PyPy
just released
recently that
they are
going to
enforce
mandatory
2FA for
all software
publishers.
And I
think this
is a great
idea.
I think
that this
is something
that should
have been
implemented
a while
back.
And I
think this
will really
help with
the whole
it's not
necessarily
dependency.
Yeah,
exactly.
Supply chain
attacks.
Not necessarily
dependency
confusion,
but it's
like a
scenario
where you
can take
over the
account
of a
person
that
has
done,
you know,
is the
author of a
certain
PyPy
library.
So I
think
2FA on
this is
really going
to make
a difference.
Yeah,
that would
be huge.
From just
like even
attacks where
someone's
social engineer
is a
domain
registrar.
That happens.
Yes,
this is
all sorts of
other things
besides that
too,
but that's
a really
good idea.
I'm surprised
it wasn't
implemented
before either.
That definitely
seems like a
no-brainer
thing.
But I do
wonder what's
going to
happen if
they don't
have that.
For example,
if somebody
just doesn't
update their
2FA and
they just
never log
into their
PyPy
account,
are they
going to
prevent them
from pushing
updates to
it or
something like
that?
Could be
interesting to
see.
Yeah,
it would
be very
interesting.
I wonder
if does
NPM do
this?
I don't
know.
I feel
like they
should.
I think it's
not mandatory
but it is
something that
you can
configure.
I'm glad
PyPy has
taken the
first step
and moving
in that
direction,
setting the
industry
standard.
My beloved
language,
Python,
just happens
to be doing
everything
right.
I love
to see
that.
Dude,
I love
it,
man.
I really
do.
I still
write Python
every day.
It's the
best.
Okay,
so news
section
done.
Corbin
switches
from
co-host
to
guest.
So,
man,
we've been
hacking
together
for
probably
five years
at this
point.
And I
don't know
that I've
ever heard
the whole
how did
you get
into
bug bounty
story.
I know
we've run
into each
other at
live hacking
events,
but my
backstory
is
Tommy DeVos
just rolled
into my
cybersecurity
class and
just started
teaching about
bug bounty
randomly
without even
being invited
to the best
of my
knowledge.
Oh,
that's so
funny.
I know,
he just
showed up
one day
and I
was like,
hello?
But yeah,
what's yours?
How did you
hear about
bug bounty
and that
whole industry?
Well,
I didn't
know.
I'd gotten
into
hacking
when I
was a
freshman
in high
school.
But I
didn't
know
bug bounty
was a
thing
or that
you
could
even
do
ethical
legal
hacking
until I
was a
junior
in high
school.
And I
was on
Twitter
and I
saw
someone's
tweet.
I think
it might
have been
Tommy
too.
I think
he was
awarded
$10,000.
Why is
he such
everyone's
origin
story?
Yeah,
and so
he was
like,
I think
he tweeted
out a
big bounty
amount
that he
got from
Yahoo
or
something.
I was
like,
what?
That's a lot
money.
He
did
this
for
what?
And so
then I
clicked on
the link
that was
in the
tweet and
then I
came across
HackerOne
and I'm
like,
whoa,
you can
get paid
to report
vulnerabilities?
So I
signed up
for HackerOne
and gave
it a
test.
It was
a struggle
at first.
I thought
it was
like a
god
at
hacking.
That's
something
that will
humble
you
really
quickly.
And so
yeah,
then I
started
doing
bug bounties
kept
after it
and
yeah,
here I
didn't
really
know
any
other
in-person
bug bounty
hunters.
You just
kind of
found it
on Twitter
and then
kind of
rolled
into it.
I had
no idea
about what
it was.
I think
I followed
Tommy on
Twitter.
I found
some other
bug bounty
hunters
on Twitter
and just
started
following
them.
I just
signed up
HackerOne.
I read
through some
There's no
HackerOne
at that point
either.
No,
there wasn't
that.
There wasn't
any
Pentester.
I don't
think there
was Pentester
Lab or
any of
those
courses
and
stuff.
I had
taught
myself
to
hack
before
that.
A lot
of going
through
exploit
DB
stuff.
Oh,
yeah.
The
classics.
Yeah.
A lot
of
just
reading
tutorials
and
reading
people's
Twitter
posts,
blogs,
and
just
trying
the
trial
and
error.
I spent
a lot
of
time
on
the
DoD
program.
I started
on public
programs and
tried to
do bug
mounties and
I just
failed
miserably.
I tried
the Department
of Defense
and I got
tons of
dupes
from that.
It was
a really
good
experience
in
practicing.
It's
so
funny,
man.
I think
I'm
getting
notifications
right
now
from
four
years
ago
of them
closing
bugs that
I reported
four years
ago.
On one
hand,
that's
impressive
that you're
still tracking
this bug.
on the
other
hand,
why?
Four
years?
Do you
endorse
bounty
as a
training
ground
for
actual
bug
bounty?
You
receive
a
bug
bounty
methodology?
Or would
you do
it
differently
if you
went
back?
Would
I do
it
differently
than
what I
did
originally?
If you
were advising
someone to
start now,
would you
say go
ahead and
start on
the DoD
program?
Or would
you try to
go straight
after bug
bounty?
That's a
hard one.
I would
say I
don't think
you can go
wrong with
either.
It took me
ten months to
get my first
bounty, but
that was okay
for me because
I was a high
schooler.
I was just
doing it in
my free
time.
hacking for
fun.
If you
have prior
experience,
for me I
didn't have
tons of
I was in
high school.
I didn't
have that
much
experience
with
computers.
Hacking.
If you
already work
as a
security
engineer,
why would
you not
go for
any
bug
bounty
program?
For
people who
are
wanting
to
work
on
fundamentals,
just all
that jazz.
I would
say work
on
recon,
all that.
Just get a
very good
solid
understanding
of different
vulnerability
classes,
different
technologies
and stuff.
I'd say go
for the
Department
of Defense
because they
have all
sorts of
stuff.
They do
have a
lot of
different
stacks.
I think
you can
see your
origin a
little bit
clearly in
your current
attack vector
methodology.
You almost
have a Jason
Haddix-ish
flow of
I'm going
to do
X amount
of recon
and I'm
going to
find these
weird ASPX
endpoints that
are like no
one ever
thought was
real.
It's not
necessarily
like,
don't get
me wrong,
I've seen
you pwn
new companies
and old
companies alike,
but I feel
like the
DoD having
such a wide
scope,
having such
an array
of technologies
and being a
little bit
more outdated
led you down
the path
to focusing
really hard
on recon
and having
that be a
key part
of your
methodology.
Would you
agree with
that?
Yeah,
I'd say
that.
And then
hacking a lot
with Naffy.
Naffy
mentioned me
a ton.
I have a lot
of Naffy
mentality when
it comes to
infrastructure
and stuff
like that
too.
Any tidbits
on that you
want to share?
I think
Naffy is an
interesting
character and
we'll probably
have him on
the pot
at some
point but
his hacking
methodology is
definitely
pretty different
from a lot
of what I've
seen.
Yeah,
no,
he finds
apps that
no one
would have
ever found
and just
completely
destroys them
once he's
found them.
That's what I
love about it.
It's like,
okay,
just like you
make new
opportunities for
yourself and
then,
yeah.
So,
I mean,
what does
that entail?
I mean,
I don't want to
give his away.
Okay,
well,
it's yours
now too.
I remember,
hold on,
I remember
this deal
though that
you had
with Naffy
a while
back and
if we have
to cut
this section
we can but
you know,
there was a
deal that
y'all made
about Naffy
working with
you and
him getting
a certain
percent of
your bounty
and you
guys were
working at
a life
hacking event
together and
that was
like what?
That was,
I think it
was that,
maybe it
was that one.
That was
probably like
four or
five years
ago,
right?
2019-ish?
Yeah,
four years
ago.
So,
I feel like
the statute
of limitations
on that is
up.
I mean,
if you don't
want to
doss your
secrets,
that's fine
if you don't
want to
disclose all
that.
But,
yeah,
I think it's
really interesting.
I know that
Naffy's approach
is largely
a virtual host
enumeration
based in a lot
of scenarios
which is
something that
not a lot
of people
poke at
and I
think mapping
out the
internal
routing
on a
company
can result
in some
crazy
stuff.
Oh,
yeah,
absolutely.
Is that
still a part
of your
methodology?
Yeah,
I look a lot
at load
balancers.
I play a lot
with load
balancers
and just
like different
Ingress
endpoints.
I mean,
the nice
thing is
when you do
it for a
long time,
you can
kind of
start
noticing
how
apps
work.
And then
also,
if you've
been in
software
development
or
architecture
or whatever,
I guess
if you've
ever played
with Kubernetes
set up
infrastructure
on that,
you get
a pretty
solid
understanding
of just
how it's
made,
how everything
works,
and you
start poking
at stuff.
Welcome to
this episode
of How It's
Made
with Corbin
Leo.
How it's
made.
And so,
okay,
so how
are you
identifying
a load
balancer?
Is that,
are you just
doing virtual
host scans
and seeing
if multiple
stuff pop
up and
then assuming
that's a load
balancer?
It kind
of depends
on the
technology,
right?
So like
with Amazon
you'll have
like CNames
to like
ELB.
Nice.
I mean you
can look
at like
you can
look at
headers
like
response
headers
will make
it obvious.
What kind
of stuff
have you
seen in
response?
So just
to break
down what
he just
said just
a second
ago,
if there's
a CName
to a
on a host
Amazon
endpoint
that has
ELB
in the
domain name
as a result
of the CName
and that's
elastic load
balancer and
that's going
to be clearly
doing some
load balancing,
right?
And then you
said in the
response headers
there's some
stuff that
might be
there.
Yep,
so like
you'll see
maybe like
let's see
like
for instance
like with
Kong you'll
see like a
header that
has like
Kong in it
and that's
like an
Ingress
you'll see
like SEO
so it'll
disclose the
technology
stack.
So like
it can
do that
then there's
other times
where like
headers aren't
and then you'll
just know
like
default
responses
like backend
not found
or something
like that.
Okay.
And then it's
just like
trying it on
a few apps
and seeing
like if
there's
like
header
you can
also just
like
kind of
think how
like
Fuff
does
or
Fuff
however you
say it
I hate
trying to
pronounce this
yeah if
you like
set
you can do
like how
Fuff does
like auto
calibration
so you like
send a couple
HTTP requests
to different
host headers
to get
a response
and if it
varies
like maybe
you'll try
fuzzy in there
but
nice
yeah it's
tricky man
I definitely
don't
I started
doing that
a little
bit
on some
apps
specific
targets
that I
know
are
vulnerable
to it
and
it's
it's not
and I even
tried to
build some
automation
around it
at some
point
starting
and this
is something
that I'll
tell people
that are
building out
the recon
flows
nowadays
is like
you know
if you
have a
bunch
of hosts
that map
you know
those hosts
are not
necessarily
only going
to map
to the IP
addresses
that they
resolve
to
so
in your
sort of
recon
framework
in your
recon
architecture
you should
be
building in
this
functionality
that is
going to be
allowing you
to map
domains
to IP
addresses
right
and I
think that
that makes
a big
it makes
difference
because you
can find
you know
different
domains
are accessible
on different
IP addresses
than the
things they
resolve to
which could
give you
different
access
you agree
yeah
and I
mean
like
a lot
of it
yeah
a lot
of it
isn't even
like
vhosting
too
it's just
like
okay
this
this host
name might
point to
like
Akamai
or
some like
IP
that isn't
resolved
but like
the chances
are
is that
that
IP
might
still
be
exposed
and
it's
just
like
the way
they're
routing
it
is
defined
this
way
but
this
host
is
still
here
and
you
just
access
it
this
way
so
that's
some
good
tips
if
you're
trying
to
keep
vhost
realm
and
enumerate
some
internal
assets
using
that
so
you
started
off
in
bug
bounty
you
just
signed
up
for
the
website
took
months
to
get
your
first
bounty
and
then
you
started
rolling
how
did
you
land
in
the
live
hacking
event
circuit
that's
a
good
question
I
think
it
was
after
I
started
getting
more
comfortable
with
bug
bounties
I
started
looking
at
yahoo
and
so
I
started
hacking
on
yahoo
a bit
and
had
some
xxcs
I think
I had
an xxc
a couple
SSRFs
and
then
I think
my
first
event
might have
been
there was
one in
New York
and it
was a
team
event
it's
like
the
only
team
event
that
was
your
first
event
I
think
it
was
my
first
event
I'm
fairly
together
before
then
at
that
point
then
because
I
feel
like
I
knew
you
at
that
point
yeah
because
I
think
like
I
knew
you
I
knew
Sam
yeah
I
think
that
yeah
I'm
pretty
sure
that
I
can't
remember
what
other
event
would
have
been
oh
no
my
first
live
hacking
event
I
was
not
a
hacker
that's
when I
was
triaging
a
hacker
one
that's
right
okay
now
it's
starting
making
yeah
more
sense
been
hacking
on
yahoo
for a
bit
and
then
I
had
done
a
semester
of
college
then
I
dropped
out
of
college
and
was
triaging
at
hacker
one
for
like
six
or
seven
maybe
eight
months
I think
it was less
than that
but
I
was
triaging
at
one
of
the
first
or
my
first
live
event
Vegas
events
at
so
I
was
doing
triage
there
that
tracks
I'd
already
known
people
from
hacking
with
them
as
well
so
yeah
that
definitely
tracks
so
that's
an
interesting
path
like
I feel
I've
sort
of
recommended
this
to
some
of
my
friends
that
are
trying
to
get
into
bug
bounty
and
are
also
not
necessarily
in
love
with
the
fact
that
bug
bounty
doesn't
have
consistent
income
is
that
hey
if you
get
started
you
get
rolling
you
start
understanding
how
vulns
can be
reproduced
and
you
start
understanding
you know
it'll
add a
little bit
more
technical
level
and
you
jump
into
a
triage
role
that
can
really
boost
your
game
yeah
I'd
agree
you
would
agree
with
that
it
definitely
also
helps
you
like
learn
even
how
to
write
better
reports
down
the
line
yeah
definitely
I would
also
recommend
that
to
people
who
are
yeah
in
that boat
as an
ex-triager
here
what
is
some
of
the
stuff
that
we
do
that's
hella
annoying
from the
triager
side
from the
triage
side
it
would
be
like
there's
people
who
just
give
you
the
URL
or
they
just
write
the
most
basic
report
with
no
information
I think
it's
gotten
a bit
different
I don't
know
how
like
this
is
like
four
or five
years
this
was
five
this was
in
yeah
so
five years
ago
now
math
yeah
so
I think
yeah
one of the
biggest
erks
I guess
was just
like
the lack
of
writing
some
people
did
it
like
just
give
you
this
at
that
point
in time
did you
have
to
rewrite
the
report
for
the
customer
yeah
okay
so
we had
our own
internal
templates
and
internal
expectations
of
what we
had to
write
and
provide
so
people
would
also
write
pages
in
that
and
then
we
had
to
condense
that
to
we
got
to
pick
every
the
important
parts
out
and
give
a
clear
concise
stuff
like
that
HackerOne
needs to
start
training
their own
offline
model
LLM
to be
able to
do that
because that
would be
pretty nice
to just
be like
okay
here's
this
Alex
Chapman
25 page
report
and I
need to
condense
this down
to a
page
or two
for the
customer
that would
be pretty
good
yeah
or like
a
HackerOne
Grammarly
yeah
right
that would
be really
good
I'm sure
you can't
use actual
Grammarly
at HackerOne
yeah
probably not
that makes
sense
that's one
thing I said
is I could
be really
cool to
have like
a language
model
like fine
tuned
to my
specific
writing
style
that would
be
amazing
yeah
well you
can train
it a little
bit
I've done
some of
the stuff
for the
pod
just sort
of taking
the writing
that we've
done
you know
with descriptions
and titles
and stuff
like that
and then
just takes
the actual
content of
the podcast
and then
you know
it says
all right
you know
here are
six suggestions
for the title
or you know
here are three
different rewrites
of the description
and stuff like that
and I think
that just provides
a nice little
you know
jump off point
and I trained
it with
the previous
you know
titles and
descriptions
and stuff like that
too so it still
has the same
sort of voice
and that sort
of thing
and I think
LLMs do a
pretty good job
of keeping
the voice
consistent
across
you know
multiple bodies
of text
so that's
pretty rad
solid
okay
so I guess
as you left
triaging
eight months
you know
max
after you
started
why did you
do that
and how do
you feel
about the
triage realm
nowadays
no I
it was a good
experience
but I was
getting kind
of burnt
out of it
and my
parents wanted
me to go
back to school
they wanted
me to go
to college
I didn't
really want
to go to
college
but I was
like screw
it it's kind
of fun
just to I
guess be a kid
not have
responsibilities
yeah for sure
and so
yeah I decided
to transfer
to a school
out in South
Dakota
and yeah
I mean it was
it was a good
experience
but I'm really
glad I went
back to school
not necessarily
just because
like I needed
the education
but it was just
like a fun
experience in
general
where I just
got to meet
friends
so you
you went
you grew up
in was it
Minnesota
yep
and then you
went out
of state
I went
out of state
to South
Dakota
so
South Dakota
for those
of you that
are not
in the U.S.
South Dakota
is like
there's like
there's nothing
in South
there is
there's Mount
Rushmore
I think
is in part
of South
Dakota
but like
like
South Dakota
is like
one of
the least
popular
and populated
states
in the U.S.
so what
made you
move from
Minnesota
and instead
of going out
of state
to any other
state
what made
you land
on South
Dakota
yeah so
it was
not trying
to diss
your new
state here
I'm just
saying
no I know
I know
gotta provide
the context
it's pretty
unique
it's super
yeah super
super unique
and like
whenever
I tell
someone I'm
from South
Dakota
I'm just
like super
confused
and I'm like
wait
and I think
like North
Dakota
or there's
two Dakotas
like where's
that
yeah exactly
but
yeah so it
was July
when I decided
I wanted to
be done
with
triaging
I believe
and I had
thought about
going to
either a school
in Minnesota
but it was so
late that
a lot of
schools didn't
have transfers
open anymore
and so there
was one school
I'd heard of
in South Dakota
that was known
for cyber
security for some
reason
oh cool
and that's
not what I
was gonna
go for
like I went
for computer
science
but I was
like hey
these people
like at least
will like
hacking
like I like
or at least
I'll find
some people
that are at
least interested
in the same
topic
and they had
applications
open super
late
so I just
like applied
to transfer
and they
yeah
accepted
nice
yeah and
then so
then I
just
yeah
went out
there
on a whim
just kind
of last
second
like why
not
I guess
yeah
close enough
to home
but also
new
how did
you enjoy
that
like
I feel
that's
one of
the things
that I
I don't
really
endorse
nowadays
is like
going to
college
for the sake
of going
to college
but I think
lately
my my
opinions
have been
kind of
coming back
around
of like
you know
while you're
young
you don't
have to
grind
you know
and yeah
go hard
on the
career stuff
you can
actually
just go
and enjoy
and college
is you know
a great place
to meet
other friends
participating
club
activities
that sort
of thing
so if you're
still looking
to grow
as a person
college might
be a good
place to do
it
yeah
no I would
agree with
that
I mean
it's hard
too
because it's
I guess
it can be
expensive
yeah
for sure
I mean
I
I definitely
enjoyed it
I don't think
I like
the computer
science stuff
I didn't
really
I don't
think I
ever needed
like the
education
I think
it was
good
I wouldn't
rely on it
just to get
to where you
want to be
like I would
never just go
through courses
and expect
you know
to
to pop out
the other end
yeah
to like
come out
like oh yeah
I know
everything
I'm ready
for this
I think
if you really
want to learn
or get
anything
that you
have to
spend
the time
doing it
yourself
personally
totally
especially
in the tech
space
is like
things move
so quickly
and technologies
change
so yeah
I mean
I think
if you want
to grow
as a person
meet some
really great
friends
and just
like really
I guess
enjoy your
life
like I
definitely
would recommend
college still
because
I mean
you have your
entire life
to grind
you might
as well
you know
enjoy some
time
going from
that like
you know
younger
like high
schooler age
where you
think you're
an adult
but then
you like
finish college
and you're
like wow
I'm a totally
different person
than I was
back then
so I think
it's good
for like
I guess
character
development
for
yeah
for sure
it definitely
is
and yeah
I think
that is
something
that I
you know
from an
early age
was also
very career
oriented
and so
I think
that having
that extra
you know
time to
to grow
figure out
who you are
not a bad
route
just to say
the least
well yeah
and it gives
you a lot
of times
to like
I guess
experiment
with what
you really
want to do
too
right
so
that's true
like for
instance
for me
like
it gave
me so much
time to
do bug
bounties
and also
like
just like
develop my
skills in
that
like
you can
learn
I guess
whatever
you want
you have
plenty
of like
free
time
to
you know
explore
hobbies
or I guess
what you want
to do with
your life
yeah yeah
for sure
so I know
I know
you did
you just said
comp sci
as well
yeah
so I did
comp sci
as well
I have to say
you know
from a hacker
perspective
I feel like
a lot of the stuff
that I learned
in comp sci
isn't incredibly
relevant
like if I want
to go and do
software engineering
and I want to like
really optimize
this algorithm
and get like
the
you know
complexity
down
you know
whatever
then it'd be
really great
to have
computer science
background
but a lot
of
a lot
hacking
isn't really
about that
and it's
more about
understanding
the full
flow of
everything
right
and I think
that's why
comp sci
is better
than a
cyber security
degree
right
it's like
I don't
think
you don't
really need
like that's
that's why
I'd always
recommend
like comp sci
if someone
doesn't know
exactly what
they want
to do
because it's
just like
it lays
down a very
solid
like baseline
but
again
it's like
I don't think
you even
need a
degree
yeah
it's just
more so
as like
I like
if we're
going to
like talk
about degrees
and like
getting one
I'd say
computer science
just because
of like
the fundamentals
rather than
like oh
we're just
gonna learn
how to
hack
and it's
like wait
you still
need all
these
fundamentals
to get
good at
it
right
yeah
I totally
agree
with that
I think
unless you're
going to a
really
reputable
cyber security
institution
then I think
it may be
better for you
to focus
specifically
on comp sci
and then
supplement
with your
own
you know
certificate
based training
towards
cyber security
but actually
Corbin
I'm gonna
disagree with
you on this
one because
I think
personally
this is the
hierarchy
right here
you've got
cyber security
degree
you've got
computer science
degree
and you've
got computer
engineering
degree
and I think
okay
so I think
all of the
people that
I like
for example
Joel
and Sam
Erb
and like
some of the
other really
like just
I feel like
I talk to
these guys
and they're
like yeah
man I
remember
like
you know
when I was
desoldering
this thing
from this
board
in college
I'm like
what
like
you know
my school
didn't have
computer engineering
yeah
that would
have been
fun
and I feel
like even
the people
that I met
at my school
that were
doing computer
engineering
instead of
computer science
I was like
man these
guys just
have a little
bit of a
deeper
understanding
of like
just like
lower
level
concepts
you know
even lower
yeah
and I think
an even better
baseline
exactly
an even better
baseline
so I was
going to say
you know
if people
are going to
go into
college
and get a
degree
I think
I would
actually
push
computer
engineering
over
comp sci
or even
cyber security
yeah I'd agree
with that
I don't
disagree
with that
yeah
that's good
okay
getting back
over to the
list over here
so I guess
let's go
let's talk a
little bit
about your
combination
of writing
and hacking
right
so I know
we talked a
little bit
about sort
of copywriting
and like
uh
just this
whole concept
of trying
to develop
yourself
as a writer
um
and then
you know
you kind
of wrote
all these
twitter threads
that went
mega viral
a while back
so any
any tips
or tricks
to share
with the
hacker
community
about
the importance
of writing
or how
to write
well
as a hacker
yeah I mean
when I was
writing those
twitter threads
I got so
much flack
from people
about like
oh you
oversimplified
this
or like
did you
really
I got
a lot
oh yeah
there was
lots of people
that were like
making fun of me
or um
not necessarily
making fun of me
just like
give me crap
or just saying
oh like
oh did the
intern write
this
like
um
people were
very
um
dang dude
I don't know
I guess being
uh
what's
I don't even know
what the word
describe that is
but that was
totally fine with me
because like
that's
not who
I was writing
for
right
so like
you have all
these people
who write
like these
like immaculate
like technical
um
writing
that's kind
of just like
a
I don't need
to stroke
my own ego
and try to
sound as
technical as
possible
because like
okay you
write that
you're making
your audience
you're alienating
people who can
understand that
you're alienating
first off
a huge audience
and you're also
only writing
for like
a really small
number of people
who might be
on the same
level as you
yeah
and like
my whole purpose
of writing
these twitter
threads
were to
um
I guess
figure out
how to explain
things clearly
and um
yeah and simplify
it too
reach a larger
larger audience
maybe get people
interested in bug
bounties
get them interested
in hacking
and like also
have them still
be able to like
understand it
and get like
intrigued in it
and maybe want to
try and learn
some of this
right
and
yeah and I think
you didn't simplify
it you know
too much
it's not like
okay
I went to
you know
the internet
and found this
directory
you know
it's like
no
here's the
you know
here's the exact
like subfinder
command I used
here's the exact
gao command I used
here's the
you know
yeah
and it's like
and so I think
it's a really nice
balance of like
um
technical content
and storytelling
which is
you know
until you've
tried it
you don't really
know how
difficult it is
because it's
it's very
challenging
yeah
I spent a lot
of time
writing those
threads
like I think
the fastest
one I wrote
was like
55 minutes
um
which was like
probably
maybe like
a waste of
time
but no
it was like
really good
to practice
um
because it's
such like
technical writing
but still writing
in a way
that's
intriguing
and
you know
like
yeah
I think
that's a great
I think that's
a great skill
I mean
being able
to captivate
an audience
is really
powerful
and it's not
something
it's not a skill
that's
that's very
commonly
you know
paired with
a high level
of technical
ability
and so
um
I think
that's
you know
one of the
podcasts that I
listen to on a
regular basis
is my first
million
and it was
talking about
how
I love that
pod
and um
one of the
things that
they've talked
about just
from a framework
perspective
is like
you don't
have to be
the best
at hacking
or the best
at blockchain
at any of
these other
things
you just
have to
take
you know
a above
average
ability
here
and combine
it with
an above
average
ability
over here
and now
you've got
a mixed
skill set
that's really
unique
and marketable
yeah
and I think
your ability
to do
something
like that
with this
writing
is really
I think
that's
amazing
so
nice stuff
there
and so
I mean
do you
really
largely
credit
Sampar's
copy this
or whatever
it is
writing course
or copy that
yeah that course
was really
good
so yeah
that's
a big
reason
why
yeah I
took that
course
and then
I wanted
to try
applying it
to something
pretty technical
and so
yeah I mean
that was
that was a
pretty
yeah it's a
great course
I still go back
and go through
it
or at least
like pieces
of it
to kind of
just like
refine writing
skills
I think
everyone
should
take a
course
on
copywriting
just because
it's like
just writing
effectively
I guess
like you
don't need
to be
super
long-winded
yeah
I think
it's
it's a
good
a good
course
but at
the same
time
it's like
this is a
problem I have
with Twitter
right now
is that
everyone's
becoming
marketed
market
marketery
yes
everything's
like a
marketing
thread
now
and it's
like
you have
to have
this
good
combination
of
like
effective
writing
but
like
actual
substance
genuine
content
yeah
because
I've
seen
so
many
like
oh
bar
just
killed
GPT-4
like
oh my
gosh
it's
everywhere
here's
prompts
you
can
use
it's
just
like
all
this
noise
of like
you don't
really
like
everything's
supposed to
be
like
when everyone's
doing the same
thing
it's just
I don't know
it's just so
you can tell
marketing
material
versus
like
you know
actual
substance
material
is still
like
captivating
I guess
yeah
lots of
bloat
out there
I think
and so
taking this
ability
to do
copywriting
or
you know
effectually
tell a story
and convey
and captivate
an audience
and transporting
this into
report writing
so
you know
I'm
interesting
to see
how
I'm
interesting
to hear
your opinion
on how
that's
affected
the severity
of your
reports
and I will
just before
I let you
answer that
I will say
Nogli
is a big
proponent
for this
as well
and you
you just
you gotta
I've collabed
with Nogli
on a couple
of reports
and I'll write
some stuff
down
and he's
like
no
how do
you ever
you
exactly
no
how do
you
what are
your thoughts
on you know
the value
of copywriting
and storytelling
in the context
of a technical
report
yeah
so like
for me
I don't
really do
like
it's not
storytelling
in my report
it's like
very technical
but
oh it's
technical
where it needs
to be
right
so like
the summary
might not be
as technical
like okay
I found
this bug
blah blah blah
this is what
it does
this is
I guess
how it works
and that's
like
pretty technical
but like
the summary
and then the
impact
are
not maybe
like
more like
copywriting
but it's just
more
just very clear
straightforward
to the point
writing
where it's like
this is the
impact
this is what
you can do
xyz
where you're
listing
explicitly
why
this is a
critical
and what
your specific
views are
on that
because
like
this is why
I think
I talked
to someone
about this
or we had
a whole
like talk
at
I think
it was one
of the
hacker
advisory board
about the
impact section
and the purpose
of the impact
section
people were like
oh well
like
it doesn't make
sense to me
because like
I just write
my impact
in the summary
and like
well for me
in my impact
section
like
I'll write
either like
I'll just
okay maybe I'll have
if I'm lazy
I'll just write
basically what I had
in the summary
otherwise
like if it's
like an actual
a critical report
I will list out
every single metric
in the CVS
piece
yeah
yeah piece
that I've
like selected
I'll explain
why I have it
set to that
and why it
should stay
set as that
and then
if the program
disagrees with me
they'll at least
have an exact
very clear
response back
of why they
disagree
or why that
should be changed
and that
leads
that helps
a lot
with like
disagreements
on severity
great tip there
I mean
I rarely go
to that level
of detail
but in the times
that I have
it's really made
those triager
misunderstandings
that sometimes
get your report
downgraded
or program
misunderstandings
that sometimes
get your report
downgraded
it's really
minimized those
so I'm actually
going to write
myself a note
right now
to go in
and do that
for the next
live hacking event
because especially
when you're at
the live hacking events
and like reports
are flying all over
the place
and triagers
are adjusting stuff
and you know
it gets really
tricky to have
those you know
complex CVSS
conversations
and if you provide
justification
for each metric
that's the word
we're looking for
metric
yeah
metrics
thank you
English
yeah
and if you provide
explanations for each
one of those
metrics
then I think
it could really
provide a lot
of clarity
yeah
and it also
like it forces
the program
to really
like dive deep
and like actually
consider your report
rather than like
okay yeah
we have this bug
I don't know
like really forces
them to think
through all the
different aspects
that maybe
they haven't
thought through
before so
yeah for sure
um
solid
uh
let's talk a little
bit about more
about your
hacking methodology
and then I also
want to talk about
some entrepreneurial
pieces as well
because that's
something you and
I have sort of
bonded over
being hackers
and entrepreneurs
at the same time
so um
that's something
that I'd like
to talk about
as well
um
so
I guess
just talking a little
bit more about
the recon
flow
we touched on
this a little
bit earlier
but you know
you're going out
there you're doing
recon and
this is a quote
that we quote
almost every episode
I love this quote
from Jay Haddix
the whole point of
recon is to find
more applications
to hack
right
and so when
do you
stop
and actually
intentionally
hack an
application
versus continuing
your recon
and um
yeah
we'll break
that question
off there
yeah
because that's
a really hard
I think that's
a hard skill
to learn
for beginners
is when to
stop doing
recon
and when to
start hacking
because it's
really easy
to get into
the like
pattern of
like okay
I'm just gonna
run subfinder
I'm gonna write
ff and everything
totally
um
and just like
keep finding
until like
maybe you
like somehow
find like
a git directory
on some host
or something
right
um
so
uh
I guess
it's pretty
difficult
um
to define
like
what exactly
will make me
stop
but a lot
of times
it's just
like
intuition
sure
so you
see
like
I'm doing
directory
brute forcing
um
I've used
like three
word lists
not finding
much
um
uh
maybe I'll
just like
hop to the
next host
um
oh I found
an interesting
directory on
this
like maybe
it's like
um
like a
react app
on this
like subdirectory
and then you
can go through
the javascript
files and start
actually hacking
and doing
like normal
um
actual
like
hacking
your hacking
methodology
or I guess
more like
pen testing
methodology
I guess
yeah
um
and then
yeah
it's just
kind of
just this
like intuition
flow that I have
kind of nailed
down
um
sometimes I'm lazy
and it's like
okay I don't
I'm just gonna run
ff on a bunch
of different hosts
and just do it
that way
or I can just
do it in the
background while
I'm looking at
something else
too
well that was
the follow-up
question to this
was like
okay so
you know
you found a
couple things
or you know
you found
you know
your 40 or
50 hosts
you're gonna
assess
and you
you go to
each host
and you
kind of do
smart ff
instead of
like normal
ff
where you
you go to
the host
you know
you're not just
brute forcing
on slash
you know
always
sometimes you're
going to the
host
and you're
saying
okay well
the index
page redirects
to slash
you know
dashboard
but then it
gives an error
or something
like that
so you
actually
brute force
slash dashboard
yeah
it's not like
oh it's an
images directory
I'm gonna key
right
you know
something like
you don't
you don't want
to waste
your bandwidth
doing that
so but like
how many
would you say
like
you know
you described
two extremes
there
you say
you described
you know
finding a specific
application
and then just
really
sort of going
deep on that
based off of
your intuition
and you also
described just
sort of
brute forcing
everything
you know
where do you
think the
average sits
like of like
all right
I'm normally
brute forcing
like three to
four applications
at a time
or 10
or 20
or one
at a time
and really
just reading
all the
javascript
files while
it's running
yeah I
typically just
do one at
a time
really
okay
for the most
part
yeah so I
will
I think
focus is also
really important
yeah
and that's
dangerous when you
try to go
after too many
things at too
many times
you're just
going to
miss
things so
typically I
can get a
pretty good
feel for
you know
like what
I want to
hack on
so it's
like I'll
do my
reconnaissance
and it's
kind of just
this process
of like
filtering all
this data
down to
like a
single thing
at a
time
and so
I will
typically
do recon
until I
find a
host
that's
interesting
then I'll
do recon
on that
host
and so
I'll do
like
directory
brute
forcing
if
there's
like
dashboard
on it
then I'll
start like
reading through
javascript files
and just start
like hacking
it
solid
then when I'm
sick of that
single one
I'll go hop
to something
else
that's cool to hear
because I
definitely didn't
see your methodology
that way
I figured you'd
be doing
you know
directory
brute forcing
across multiple
hosts
you know
10-20 hosts
on a regular
basis
but for you
and I think
this is something
really cool
to highlight
with Corbin's
methodology
here
is that
he's a
little bit
of a recon
hacker
but he also
is like
sort of a
deep recon
hacker
right
because
you're
going
going to
a host
you're
doing a lot
of directory
brute
forcing
you're
doing a lot
of
you know
enumeration
but also
you're doing
that in a
smart way
you know
you're
reading the
JavaScript
files
you're
you know
recursively
brute forcing
on folders
you've found
that sort
of thing
and
and keeping
your attention
on one
host
which I think
is really
I think
that's key
yeah
or also
like adjacent
hosts as well
so like
JavaScript file
might reference
some other
APIs
and like
working on
those too
because it's
all a part
of this
like one
bigger
application
so
so you're
taking
you know
you're breaking
apart the JS
file
you're saying
okay
these are the
adjacent hosts
to this
the hosts
that work
on this
specific
or that
power
this
specific
website
and you're
using
you know
text from
the other
page
using
references
from that
JS file
to enumerate
stuff on the
APIs as well
yeah
exactly
so that's
that's pretty
huge too
because there
will be so
many like
API endpoints
you'll never
be able to
guess
yeah
almost out
you know
all this
other like
contextual
all these
other contextual
pieces
so
man I got
I got to
find this
this tweet
from
from you
I was just
reading through
some of your
tweets that you
that you put
out
previously
and
he was like
oh here it is
right here
I'll link it
to you
hold on
I'm going to
send it to
you in
discord
scroll down
and we'll put
this tweet
in the description
as well
this is
Corbin's
tweet on
hacking the
military
but scroll
down to
like
scroll down
to like
the fourth
or no
it's the
third tweet
and it says
yeah
after reading
the JS
files in
directory
brute force
I came
across
this
endpoint
squirm
upload
course
dot
ASPX
and I'm
like
what do you
what is that
was that
you're brute
forcing
like
no
how did
you
so
but
you got
that
ASPX file
from reading
the JS
file
and then I guess
maybe you found
the full path
by like
brute forcing
some directories
and such
yeah
and so
like
I
one thing
that I do
that I don't
know if
anyone else
does
is
I'll find
a
like
a directory
called like
JavaScript
and I'll
just
I'll brute
force
for JavaScript
files
that's
big
so
I've done
that
and also
I've tried
to find
CSS files
because
sometimes
I'll do
like
import
image
from
like
this
and it'll
be like
super long
directory
that you might
not be able to find
but yeah
I think I was
I was
brute forcing
through
four JavaScript
files
and I
I had
like come
across a new
directory with
like JavaScript
files and I
brute forced
some in there
then that's
when I came
across that
ASPX file
so you
you actually
brute forced
for the JS
files
which led
you to
this more
complex
ASPX
endpoint
yep
so it's
like going
through
JavaScript
files
to find
some
endpoints
and then
brute forcing
those
and then
in one
of those
there's
like a
reference
to that
nice
that's
a great
takeaway
I like
that
nice man
well that's
so
we're
at about
an hour
now
I did
have
one
other
sort
of
status
of yours
that
or
post
of yours
that I
wanted to
look at
you know
what
I think
we're going
to save
this one
for a
different time
because I
did want
to follow
up on
some
entrepreneurial
stuff
as well
so
currently
okay
a couple
months
back
you
announced
breachless
AI
and
I
kind
of
want
to
hear
about
some
lessons
learned
from
that
because
it
seems
like
you
pivoted
over
to
boring
mattress
co
now
which
I
love
and
I'll
hold
up
my
phone
for
the
YouTube
video
I've
got
boring
mattress
co
on the
back
of my
phone
and I've
actually
had a couple
people
ask me
about
it
already
so
you're
getting
free
marketing
off
of
this
yes
thank you
but
you know
what
happened
to
breachless
AI
and
what
kind
of
lessons
did
you
learn
from
that
yeah
so
I'll
first
introduce
it
too
because
people
may
not
know
yeah
so
breachless
the idea
behind
that
was
I
going
to
use
artificial
intelligence
to
basically
the idea
was
to
do
analysis
of
incoming
emails
and
adding
well
to take
a step
behind
the
currency
it was
like
to help
prevent
social
engineering
attacks
right
and so
like
you have
companies
like
know
before
like
all these
different
companies
that are
doing
these
what are
they
called
so
security
awareness
trainings
yeah
and so
it's like
you force
employees
to go
through
really
boring
outdated
videos
that are
like
20 years
old
or
they're
just
like
really
irrelevant
to
like
the average
person
like
a hacker
might think
oh wow
these are
like
really funny
these are
really cool
and you have
your average
Joe
is like
this is
the stupidest
thing I've
ever had
to watch
what if
this
and the
problem
too
is like
okay
yeah
you watched
a video
four times
a year
and you never
remember it
in the moment
and so
my idea
was to
add
context
to
actual
emails
in like
the form
of a banner
to help
people identify
social engineering
attacks
or potential
social engineering
attacks
just like
write in each
email
and so
that was
the idea
there
it didn't
go very
far
I had
actually
had a
pretty
sizable
wait list
I think
I had
like
to
nice
dude
companies
on that
wait list
that's a lot
actually
yeah
it was
actually
pretty decent
there were
some pretty
decent sized
companies
on that
but what
made me
move away
from it
was I
wanted to
bootstrap
the company
I didn't
want to
raise
venture
capital
and
it was
also a
pretty
crowded
space
just
phishing
anti-phishing
stuff
yeah
just like
email security
stuff
I don't
think that
necessarily
should have
like
maybe
turned me
away so
much
but I
think the
biggest
issue
was
the
requirements
for a lot
of companies
have for like
SOC 2 audits
so
what is that
it's like
basically
companies
when they
want
to use
let's see
like I don't
want to mess
it up
sure
while you're
looking that
it's like
it's a
compliance
it's like
a compliance
standard
which is
like how
organizations
manage
like
data
yeah
and so
like you
have to go
through this
like compliance
process
and be able
to like
provide this
to each
customer
that like
asks for
it
gotcha
and so
that costs
at least
like $150,000
and I didn't
really want to
pay that
out of pocket
with
and
you know
without VC
develop an MVP
and then have
you know
have to pay $150,000
out of pocket
just
just for that
like that's a pretty
big expense
out of pocket
especially without
raising money
and so
that's a huge barrier
to entry
for new players
yeah
geez
it's a very
yeah
it's
it's big
and
there are people
I think that
I think you can find
an auditor
like you could
probably give like
equity to
and pay them
a lot less
but
yeah
with that
it was just
kind of like
a turn off
and
then
my co-founder
day
he was talking
about getting
back into
the mattress
industry
space
yeah
and so
I jumped over
to that
and I was also
very intrigued
by you know
the consumer goods
so I thought
that would be
a cool thing
to tackle
is such a cool
thing to go
after too
like I feel
like that
is
such a
traditional
industry
yeah
so
hopped over
to that
I still think
the Breachless
product
the idea
there is
pretty cool
if someone
can like
I can see
the gears
turning in your
head still
like as you're
talking about
I know
I still love
it
yeah
I know
I still
love the idea
and I don't
think it's a bad
idea
it's just
like
you know
maybe someday
yeah
would you consider
selling or handing
off that
email list
or wait list
of companies
to somebody
who wanted to
take a stab
at Breachless
yeah
I mean
I'd still be
interested in
like being
involved with it
somewhat
but it's just
like do you
want to raise
venture capital
it's just like
a whole nother
completely different
than you know
just a good
well there you go
if any of you
other hackers
out there
are interested
in an
entrepreneurial
opportunity
I love the
product
I think
it would be
really
I think
it's a really
good fit
you know
having a
email banner
having some
sort of add-on
for G Suite
or for Outlook
and you know
who knows
Microsoft might
just have this
and there's now
with GPT-4
they'll be able
to do that too
yeah
well that's
the other thing
is I feel like
maybe my
timelines are
a little off
but did you
launch this
before
chat GPT
blew up
I think it was
about
yeah
or at least
it was very early
just before
yeah
it was really early
I don't
it was before
chat GPT was released
yeah
and so
that's
man
they had GPT-3
yeah
the API for that
and that was it
that was a great timing
of the market
I think
you know
like
that before that
whole thing blew up
you know
you had already
launched this
and so
yeah
yeah man
I've still got
I've still got high hopes for it
I would love to see it
at some point
pop up
so definitely let me know
if you're getting back
into it again
because I think
that'd be really
I think that'd be a really cool
thing to be involved with
and also
you know
I hope
you find someone in the industry
who's got the bandwidth
to take it on
because I would love to use it
in an organization
yeah
all right
I guess
the other question
that I have
is like
what
what sort of
hacker
entrepreneurial
takeaways
did you
did you have
from that experience
of pivoting
like
did you
was that a hard move
for you to pivot
away from it
I could see a little bit
of
cognitive dissonance
I think
in your eyes
yeah
I mean
it wasn't
it's different
because
like
it's still
I still like the idea
but
I'm also
like
I don't know
where
I
like I'm still optimistic
but I'm like pessimistic
in other ways
because
like yeah
the cybersecurity
field
is like
extremely saturated
from where it used to be
but at the same time
I like the idea
a lot
and I think
it could be
very helpful
but then
I'm also like pessimistic
about like
okay why can't
Microsoft just add that
yeah
which I think
they very well could
now
I think they probably
will
I think
with all their
integrations
it's probably
a good thing
I did
step away from it
but
you know
there's definitely
market risk there
I think
you know
because
you could easily
get replaced
by a big player
or
you could get acquired
by a big player
you know
that's the other thing
yeah
for someone who wants
like a quick
quick integration
yeah
so
I mean
I
I'm not like
I guess
worried about it
it was actually
relatively easy
for me
to
to pivot
jump away
it was
first it was like
it's a little
a little sad
because I liked the idea
but at the same time
I was like
I had all these other
kind of
had some doubts
but
yeah
I knew
it's
where I needed
to go next
and
I guess
I had to just
trust my gut
on that
yeah for sure man
well I'm
glad to see
that you
you know
were able to
successfully assess
the
difficulties
of that
specific challenge
and pivot
and
I'm excited
to see where
Boring Mattress Co
is headed
do you have any
update on that
last I heard
you
you got your
prototype out to the house
yes
it's super comfy
I've been sleeping
on it for
a while now
I love it
it's super
super amazing
so I mean
are you going to
make a lot more
make much
modification to that
mattress
or are you guys
going to just
move forward
with it
not to the
mattress itself
I think we're
still iterating
on the covers
that's like
the outside
of it
that's like
you have like
all your foam
there's like
fire stock on it
and then
the cover is like
the outside
like the aesthetic
we're still
figuring out
that
that piece
of it
gotcha
we're not going
to take any
I think
let me just
go ahead
and add
my two cents
to the mattress
industry here
I got these
bed sheets
and this is bed sheets
it's a different
arena
but who knows
maybe you could do
a package deal
or something
no we will
probably at some point
and so
I've got these bed sheets
and for one
there's like
these bamboo
bed sheets
that are just
super
like
cool
and
cool meaning
like
you know
not
like the opposite
of hot
not like
cool as in
amazing
they're very cool
you know
and they're awesome
and I love them
and it really helps
me sleep better
but also
they have this
little pocket
on the side
of the bed
it's built into
you know
the side of the
mattress
the fitted sheet
or the fitted sheet
that goes on the
mattress
and it's perfect
size to like
put your phone in
and it's just like
such a nice
little thing
you know
you're in bed
you got your phone
and then you just
slide it right into
his pocket
so anyway
there's your little
tidbit
you know
cut me in
whenever you make
millions off of
that
and yeah
we'll be good
cool
well dude
thanks for coming
on to the pod
I tried to
you know
dedicate this
last section
to the
boring mattress
company
but
you got any
other shoutouts
you want to
make
not really
solid
shoutouts
everyone
hacking out
there
yeah
well
you can find
Corbin at
twitter.com
slash
hacker underscore
and then
boring mattress
company is
twitter.com
slash
boring mattress
which somehow
you got
that's awesome
that's because
no one in the
industry is going
to admit
that mattresses
are boring
yeah
that's true
they've got
that's
also why
I like
the brand
that's a great
mark
yeah
and I love
the copy
as well
on the
description
for the
for your
twitter page
so I'll
I'll let
I won't even
read it out
loud
I'll just
say
for those
listening
yeah
go
go to the
page
follow the
account
and read
the
description
because
I think
it's a
great
example
of
engaging
copy
so
all right
man
well thanks
for coming
on
appreciate
it
yeah
thanks for
having
me
that's
the pod
that was
a great
episode
with Corbin
always love
having him
on the
pod
if you
enjoyed
this
content
please
head over
to
youtube.com
slash
at
critical
thinking
podcast
drop a
like
and
subscribe
and also
don't forget
to stay
engaged
on your
podcast
app of
choice
via
subscribing
or following
or whatever
it is
you do
the podcast
around was a
little weird
so just
I'm sure
you'll figure
it out
thanks
see y'all
next week